qualsiasi attività umana
a dare vita a una certa di una certa di
inquinamento ed è piuttosto difficile
non farlo potremmo tranquillamente dire
che da quando l'essere umano abita su
questo pianeta abbiamo gradualmente
perso quel che chiamiamo natura e
naturale un pezzettino sempre di più
viviamo infatti nell'antro pocenia era
geologica nella quale il globo viene
plasmato secondo l'azione dell'uomo
oggi noi parliamo di impronta di
carbonio per indicare la domanda di
risorse naturali e le conseguenti
emissioni di gas serra che ci sono che
ci servono per
apportare delle trasformazioni
all'ambiente naturale da parte dell'uomo
queste avvengono perché noi dobbiamo
adattare l'ambiente alle nostre esigenze
e migliorare la qualità della nostra
vita
gli stili di vita di noi abitanti dei
paesi del primo mondo sono devastanti
per il pianeta e non vanno di pari passo
con la sua biocapacità ovvero la sua
capacità di creare risorse e man mano
rigenerarle ogni anno noi sfruttiamo
oltre il 60 per cento della capacità di
rigenerazione del pianeta e della sua
capacità di fornirci degli ecosistemi
per vivere
viviamo abitiamo in un pianeta finito ma
ci viviamo come se questo potesse non
finire mai
il riscaldamento alla quale assistiamo
da oltre 150 anni è dovuto per il 97 per
cento dalle attività innescate dall'uomo
e sono la principale causa della crisi
climatica che noi stiamo vivendo
i due principali settori che emettono la
maggior parte delle
quantità di gas climalteranti sono
quelli legati alla produzione energetica
e quelli legati alla produzione
alimentare legata all'industria delle
proteine animali
qualcuno dice che dovremmo concentrarci
o sull'una o sull'altra ma questo
purtroppo non è vero perché per restare
dentro ai limiti imposti dall'accordo di
parigi dopo dobbiamo muoverci in
entrambi i sensi quindi dobbiamo sì a
limitare l'utilizzo di fonti fossili che
diminuire le emissioni di gas dovuti all
industria alimentare
è stato dimostrato che se anche mai noi
riuscissimo ad azzerare completamente le
emissioni provocate dall industria
energetica
quello che ci rimane da parte
dell'industria alimentare ci porterebbe
oltre il carbon budget
che ci porterebbe a sforare limite di
1.5 gradi negli ultimi
60 anni
il consumo di carne in tutto il mondo è
più che raddoppiato e questo è dovuto al
crescita della popolazione e alla
crescita economica dei paesi ea
fisiologicamente portato a un aumento
del numero degli animali allevati
secondo le statistiche della fao
noi uccidiamo ogni anno tra i 70 e gli
80 miliardi di animali da reddito una
media di 200 milioni di animali al
giorno se noi ci dessimo dello stesso
numero di esseri umani
la nostra specie si estinguerebbe in
poco più di un mese
non abbiamo mai mangiato così tanti
animali
sempre secondo la fao il solo
allevamento di animali costituisce ed
emette almeno il 14.5 della totale
percentuale di emissioni di gas serra
nonostante ci fornisca solamente il 18
per cento delle calorie a livello
globale e richieda da noi il 77 per
cento dei terreni agricoli che vengono
utilizzati per coltivare i mangimi che
verranno dati agli animali che poi noi
mangeremo e per ospitarli negli spazi
dove vengono allevati quindi allevamenti
intensivi estensivi e pascoli
e questo è il grafico che lo spiega
quanto impatta l'intero ciclo di
produzione che passa dalla dal campo
all'allevamento arriva sulla nostra
tavola e va anche oltre
l'analisi dei processi produttivi
utilizza come principale parametri di
impronta ambientale
l'emissione dei gas serra
la l'utilizzo delle risorse idriche e la
capacità dei terreni di rigenerare
quello che hanno dato quindi carbon
water ecologica al footprint queste
variano a seconda di cosa dove come
produciamo e dipende dai metodi di
coltivazione dei packaging e dai
trasporti sono tutte delle variabili
però c'è una cosa che rimane uguale per
tutti quanti ed è l'indice di
conversione alimentare che ci sta ad
indicare la quantità di cibo che serve
per alimentare un animale e la sua
crescita che si
dimostrano ogni volta svantaggiosi e
fanno e dimostrano le linee dei
l'inadeguatezza ecologica di una dieta
ricca di proteine animali
questa è la doppia piramide alimentare e
ci mostra
l'impatto che hanno i cibi animali sul
clima e l'impatto che la salute
esattamente lo stesso perché i cibi che
hanno il più alto impatto a livello
ambientale sono gli stessi che hanno il
più alto impatto sulla nostra salute in
modo negativo e che quindi noi dovremmo
consumare meno frequentemente la carne
rossa e oggi l'alimento con il maggiore
impatto ambientale nonché la prima causa
di deforestazione al mondo e il nostro
pianeta non è più in grado di sostenere
nella produzione intensiva
l'ultimo report dell ipcc che è
l'intergovernamental panel on climate
change pubblicato ad agosto 2021 ci
racconta come se noi riuscissimo a
diminuire le emissioni dovute agli
allevamenti intensivi ed industriali e
abbracciare una dieta a base vegetale
riusciremo a diminuire di almeno il 21
per cento le emissioni totali di gas
climalteranti sul pianeta
quando noi proponiamo di diminuire o
eliminare i prodotti di origine animale
ci avventuriamo sempre in un territorio
impervio perché mangiare carne è parte
della nostra cultura è parte dei nostri
riti delle nostre tradizioni delle
nostre abitudini a livello individuale e
collettivo e sarà anche che siamo
italiani quindi guai a toccarci il cibo
ma il cibo non è solo questo il cibo è
una scelta e come ogni tradizione
si evolve e cambia con noi e con il
periodo storico che stiamo vivendo
fatto sta che ci dovremmo chiedere siamo
nella posizione di poter scegliere che
cosa o chi mangiare ogni giorno tre o
più volte al giorno ho detto chi perché
tra le questioni sollevate dall
industria dei cibi animali vi è anche
quella etica perché questi prodotti
prima della loro trasformazione
sarebbero degli individui questi
prodotti prima di diventare degli
riconoscibili cotolette hamburger di
stecche
insaccati erano degli animali senzienti
con delle comprovate capacità cognitive
ed emotive
noi esseri umani siamo quasi 8 miliardi
ma rappresentiamo solamente lo 0,01 per
cento della vita su questo pianeta a
livello di biomassa e relativamente
pochi ma dagli albori dell'inizio della
nostra società con l'avvento
traduzione dell'agricoltura e poi delle
attività industriali
siamo stati capaci di ridurre dell 83
per cento il numero degli animali
selvatici
qui vediamo gli altri e di oltre la metà
delle piante
negli ultimi 60 anni noi abbiamo
assestato i colpi finali e abbiamo
modellato la vita su questo pianeta a
nostro piacimento decidendo che specie
dovevano andarsene e che specie
avrebbero dovuto continuare a crescere
con un obiettivo ben preciso ed è così
che noi abbiamo letteralmente creato un
esercito di mucche polli e maiali
destinati a diventare il nostro cibo
questi sono i numeri di questo famoso
esercito quindi il 30 per cento degli
uccelli presenti su questo pianeta sono
a specie selvatiche il restante 70 per
cento sono animali allevati
intensivamente sono tacchini galline
ovaiole polli
quando invece guardiamo i mammiferi che
abitano sulla terra le proporzioni os
proporzioni sono ben più peggiori il 36
per cento dei mammiferi siamo noi esseri
umani un altro 4 per cento è costituito
da specie selvatiche che ormai sono una
rarità il restante 60 per cento è
costituito di animali mammiferi allevati
intensivamente allo scopo di diventare
cibo tappezzeria pelle e molto altro
ecco abbiamo letteralmente trasformato
una parte di mondo in una prigione per
animali questi numeri ci mostrano quanto
piccola sia l'umanità eppure quanto
grande sia la nostra impronta sulla vita
su questo pianeta è un impronta
sproporzionata dominante distruttiva e
abbiamo assolutamente bisogno di
rivederla viene spontaneo chiedersi se
per cambiare le cose non dovremo solo
pensare a come cambiare il modo di
produrre la carne ma cambiare il nostro
rapporto con la carne e quindi cambiare
il nostro rapporto con gli animali che
finora abbiamo sempre solo considerato
cibo gran parte di noi è a disagio con
l'idea che la opzione di carne latte
uova pelle comporti fare del male agli
animali e vorrei chiedere a voi quanti
di voi sono mai stati dentro un
allevamento intensivo
quanti di voi
ci porterebbero i bambini la domenica a
vedere come si fa la carne come si va in
un mulino
quanti di voi hanno mai ucciso visto
uccidere gli animali che mangiano
quanti di voi sono tranquilli nel
guardare i documentari e report che ci
raccontano che cosa succede dentro gli
allevamenti intensivi
ecco non siamo tanti
non siamo tanti perché fa male anche a
noi vedere queste cose a volte ci schifa
però continuiamo a considerare normale
mangiare tutta questa quantità di
animali tolstoj diceva se i macelli
avessero le pareti di vetro saremo tutti
vegetariani
l'industria dei cibi animali ha fatto
anche un grandissimo lavoro di green
marketing e ci mostra sui prodotti delle
confezioni di cibi animali che
acquistiamo le immagini felici di
animali spensierati che pascolano
brucano in queste distese di verdi
immense e abbiamo assistito negli ultimi
anni all'utilizzo della parola benessere
animale parolina magica che serve un po
a edulcorare la realtà
la verità è che però la maggior parte
degli allevamenti a livello mondiale e
anche in italia sono intensivi e anche
tutta la nostra produzione dop quindi le
eccellenze della nostra gastronomia made
in italy fanno parte di questo modello
produttivo e questi sono i numeri degli
allevamenti intensivi in italia
93.3 per cento degli allevamenti bovini
sono intensivi 99.3 per cento degli
allevamenti suini e avicoli sono
intensivi il 55 per cento delle galline
ovaiole vive in gabbia
è passata una legge per cui le le gabbie
dovranno essere smantellate entro il
2027 però questa al momento è la
situazione è questa questo il report
dieci anni di zootecnica in italia
questo enorme numero immenso di essere
viventi è costretto a vivere in
condizioni quanto più lontane da quelle
naturali sono animali da sempre
addomesticati che vengono al mondo con
l'obiettivo di diventare del cibo viene
loro impedito loro normale la loro
normale interazione sociale tra tra
simili spesso i movimenti a volte anche
la luce del sole ma questo non è
evitabile se non sa non è possibile
rispondere all'immensa domanda di carne
di prodotti animali che il mercato ci
richiede a prezzi bassi garantendo agli
animali una vita felice
bisogna produrre
molto velocemente e tenendo e mantenendo
i costi bassi e si fa molta molto
riferimento al garantire a questi
animali una morte indolore quando
francamente la morte la parte meno
peggiore di una vita vissuta così
alcuni di noi si definiscono amanti
degli animali
alcuni di noi si definiscono contro
l'abuso degli animali ma non riescono a
delineare quello che ritengono giusto a
quello che poi fanno però è
importantissimo per noi
fare questo passaggio è necessario
allineare i nostri pensieri alle nostre
azioni altrimenti nulla cambierà mai
quello che noi stiamo facendo agli
animali o che scegliamo per loro lo
stiamo facendo noi e riflette il livello
del nostro progresso
non è possibile pensare a una salute una
one hit mondiale che riguardi noi e
tutta la vita su questo pianeta se
continuiamo a mantenere un modello di
produzione alimentare che sfrutta
risorse terreni animali e persone
possiamo anche chiamarla scelta
personale e quella di mangiare gli
animali però purtroppo la situazione
ambientale e climatica è oggettiva e
riguarda tutti quanti
noi non dobbiamo dimenticarci che siamo
animali in primis però siamo la prima
l'unica specie che è in grado di
scegliere di indignarsi di provare
compassione
dovremmo essere
teoricamente la specie più evoluta
eppure siamo l'unica che si è rivelata
in grado di mettere in crisi la capacità
portando il pianeta che ci ospita
c'è però una buona notizia siamo anche
l'unica specie che è capace di cambiare
le sorti della propria vita e decidere
come devono girare le cose
in conclusione io so che tutta questa
mole di informazioni di numeri vi dati è
destabilizzante non si sa bene come
prenderla però a livello personale
decidere di ridurre o eliminare i
prodotti di origine animale è la via più
semplice per supportare la per la
preservazione di habitat ecosistemi
biodiversità risorse e di promuovere la
giustizia ambientale e alimentare anche
quella sociale
perché l'approccio ecologico e anche di
carattere etico e il futuro dell'umanità
passerà anche da come noi impareremo a
riconcepire il cibo in virtù di questa
nostra tanto proclamata superiorità di
sapiens vogliamo dimostrare di esserne
capaci
[Applauso]